so with all this talk about election
fraud let me tell you why i'm concerned
that the results of the election as
they're being reported
might not be entirely accurate and i
think the first the first few reasons
why
you know if i'm making the case um have
nothing to do necessarily with with
intentional fraud in that even if there
was no indication of any sort of like
shenanigans happening or anything weird
happening which there is indication of
that but even without that
um there would still be a reason to go
back and look again and make sure
there'd still be reason to be concerned
that the results aren't accurate because
number one it's an extremely close
election
with the results in some states coming
down to less than one percent
and that's already within the realm of
where you can where you can have uh
a recount and when you've got a hotly
contested election
and and comparatively few votes are
going to determine the results
then there's reason to go back and make
sure everything was done right number
two
we have never seen so many ballots
mailed in so many ballots sent in before
the election
early voting uh this mass universal
mail-in voting
we've never seen this before it's never
been anything like this so this is a
it's a whole new world we're in it's not
a world we should be in
because it should be you vote by showing
up to the polls on election day
and uh voting begins when voting begins
on election day and it ends with voting
ends on election day
there's no submitting votes before
certainly no no no
no submitting votes after that's the way
it should go unless you're active duty
military or something you've got a
really good excuse
everybody else should have to be there
bright smiling faces
on election day to vote in person that's
not the way it it's working and so
there's all kinds of
problems that we know of there are
problems at a minimum
and that's just from what we know
massive delays ballots seeming to appear
out of nowhere you know things are being
reported and then backtracked and
everything else
we need to understand what's happening
here i think it would it would be insane
to just take the results as they were
first reported
when the states have been already
backtracking and it's pretty clear
that the people in the middle of
counting the votes and tabulating it
don't know exactly what they're doing
and they're pretty
overwhelmed number three there's a
widespread belief that donald trump is a
real life
fascist dictator who's effectively
murdered hundreds of thousands of people
and plans to murder thousands more
that's obviously
false and ridiculous but it's what
people believe is what they've been told
and so this creates an enormous perhaps
overwhelming incentive
to cheat and it's another reason to go
back and check again
if if you thought that you were counting
votes
for hitler wouldn't you feel like you
want to cheat
wouldn't you at least feel tempted to
this and this but this is what the media
has told people and there are millions
of americans who
seem to believe it and then we get into
some of the suspicions
the suspicious things that we know about
um they taped up the windows in michigan
where they were counting ballots taped
the windows up so that nobody could see
them doing it what could be a legitimate
reason
for taping up the windows no one can see
uh in north carolina they're now saying
they won't update their total vote count
until next week
november 12th you've got you've got
election officials who are you know just
taking their time they're going to take
a sabbatical
go up to a mountaintop to contemplate
the mysteries of existence
and i don't know they'll announce the
results sometime next spring we're all
supposed to sit around
that's very strange in pennsylvania
they're allowing ballots to be counted
even if they don't arrive until
three days after the election and even
if they're not clearly postmarked for
the deadline
okay for before the deadline that that
is
so there's reason to be worried about
that too especially the stuff that's
going on in pennsylvania
and especially when you consider that
pennsylvania officials are in the can
for biden and they're not
hiding it the pennsylvania attorney
general announced a day before
the election that biden would win the
secretary of state of pennsylvania who's
in charge of
of the vote count she said on twitter a
couple of years ago
that using the title president before
the word trump
demeans the office of the presidency
this is that's her view this is an
extremely
partisan person who hates trump so much
that to simply call him president
is demeaning to the office in her mind
and
she's in charge of the vote count is
there reason at least to suspect that
maybe those
late ballots that they're allowing are
being allowed and the rules are being
loosened and changed at the last minute
because these people who hate trump hate
trump and want him gone
is the reason to maybe possibly consider
that and be worried about that
yeah of course there is of course there
is so
count every vote yes
but make sure they're legal and make
sure it's done right that's my position
i don't think it's very should be
controversial
uh it shouldn't be it shouldn't be
scandalous or anything like that i think
we all should be able to agree on this
but we can't and that's a pretty sad
state of affairs